have you talked to the president I have  not I have not talked one now in almost  two years I think largely because his  lawyers have suggested that we not speak  and my lawyers agree so we are not in  touch  do you miss talking to him yeah I really  do  I mean we're you know I've known him for  40 years  we're very good friends you know I don't  agree with everything he does I agree  with a lot of what he does sometimes  they like do things differently but he  was at my wedding when I got married I  was at the wedding for four he and  Melania and Yvonne he and Marla  pardoning and I was at the waiting room  for both of his parents very friendly  with his sister who's a federal judge  who I hope to get on the bench so yeah I  do I do miss it one more Jim and Sam  catch up with full episodes and  interviews from celebrity guests anytime  on demand using the Sirius XM app